okay
[Music]
okay
people versus james and jennifer
cromwell
probably duncan numbers two one zero
zero six six five one and two one zero
zero six six five two nine appearances
on the record please starting with the
prosecuting attorney
[Music]
good morning i'm sheena smith on behalf
of jennifer crumley for the purpose of
exam
and today i am going to represent miss
crumley
and my partner is going to represent mr
crumbly so that we can keep our
arguments clean and separate
good morning marielle layman on behalf
of james crumbly
so just for clarification the in terms
of any cross-examination and direct
examination ms smith you will be taking
cross-examination and direct examination
for miss crumbly only and ms lima will
be doing it for mr public that's correct
your honor okay
just regarding that aspect we have
discussed
a potential conflict every period i do
believe that is appropriate for
defendants both defense counsel to
acknowledge a potential conflict to
place that way around the record yes um
i have made the record of that on each
appearance complaining and doing it
today as well
again um as both of you have been aware
and i've made both of you aware of the
fact there's potential for a conflict of
interest in this case due to the fact
that your attorneys are
representing you and they are attorneys
and counsel in the same firm
but ms crumbly do you understand any
potential conflict that might exist with
both of these attorneys representing
both you and your husband
and mr crumbling yes ms crumbly knowing
that potential conflict are you willing
to waive any conflict that may exist and
proceed today with ms smith
representing you here for purposes of
the preliminary examination yes
mr crumbly what about you do you uh are
you willing to waive any potential
conflicts that exist with miss lehmann
representing you knowing that
miss smith is representing hillary yes
yes
all right um before we move forward
we've got a couple of um
motions that were filed for the record
today is the daytime suffer the
preliminary examination in this case
um the attorneys have had the
opportunity to meet with each other
um regarding some of the exhibits is
there still the necessity to address
that motion
uh
[Music]
yes there is
and
uh miss layman is going to argue that
motion
good morning your honor
the defense did file a motion um for a
more compressed witness list and to
adjourn
um we have reviewed the discovery that
we received from the prosecution at the
time you're on may i removed my mask
as long as i've ever been as comfortable
thank you
at the time of filing our motion there
were a number of materials that we had
not received from the prosecution since
filing the motion the prosecution has
elected to provide additional discovery
to us on february 1st february 2nd
february 3rd and february 4.
we did again ask the prosecution to
provide us with a more
um specific witness list the original
witness list that was provided was
approximately 30 witnesses we asked for
a shorter witness list so the
prosecution provided us with a list of
16 witnesses
we did ask them for more specifics
regarding their witnesses so that we
could better focus our attention on
preparing with our clients and also
preparing ourselves for the preliminary
examination today in reviewing the
materials that were provided on february
i believe second and february 4th
we learned that there were some
materials that had not been provided by
the prosecution to us specifically in
regarding one of the witnesses that they
expect to take the longest today and
that's detective wagrowski
we have met with the prosecution the
prosecution indicates that it sounds
that they do have the materials that
have not been provided to us but they
have not provided them um
it's been
your honor we have not been able to
review their reports specifically
created by the detective
video specifically created by the
detective
it's our understanding that those
reports may or may not be used today but
that doesn't mean that they don't
contain information that could be
relevant to the defense
in your honor in the amount of discovery
that has been provided to
us by the prosecution so far there are
at least 67 hours of recordings
um as we've made the court aware in
order to have in-person visits with our
clients we have to obtain a court order
for each visit we have to obtain a
negative pcr covid test at least 72
hours before the visit i'm sorry no more
than 72 hours before the visit and we
have to schedule the in-person visit
with our clients
we did have we were able to successfully
schedule two visits with our clients
last week
however we have not been able to review
all of the
recorded discovery even all of the
reported discoveries specific to some of
the witnesses today
because there was other there were other
materials and matters that we needed to
discuss
um if we do want to visit with our
clients your honor as i'm sure the court
is aware if we don't do it in person
it's done through a software which quite
frankly your honor has failed us more
times than it hasn't um and we're also
limited in time on those visits we're
limited to half an hour at a time and we
can't schedule multiple visits
back-to-back
um so your honor it's it's obviously
been very difficult to prepare for this
examination with the amount of discovery
that the prosecution has provided
um and the amount that the prosecution
has provided that's relevant to our
clients is also buried within the amount
of discovery that they've provided to us
um so your honor is even though we've
taken a number of steps to
effectively prepare for our preliminary
exam today we do still have concerns
that
that there are things that we are
missing um we just had a conversation
about text messages that we haven't seen
your honor so
the prosecution has indicated that they
may have an explanation for why we
haven't seen them but we do still have
concerns judge and
today even the prosecution indicated
that their list is even shorter than the
16 that they provided to us as recently
as last friday
so judge
the the police reports that we reviewed
indicate that there are dates with which
pro law enforcement has provided
over a hundred gigabytes of data to the
product probably over 200 gigabytes of
data to the prosecutor's office and
we've received that data
sometimes weeks later
so judge we do have concerns about the
material that's been provided to us we
do have concerns that we're missing
material that will be relevant to the
preliminary examination
and we we can't be effective without
being able to review everything judge so
we are asking that the court adjourn the
preliminary examination for these
reasons
response thank you john we just spent 45
minutes made with defense counseling
everything in this binder that we put
together for the courts most defense has
been turned over now just a few minutes
ago this smith approached me and said
there's a text thread that she didn't
think she had or may have been deleted
our expert in computer crimes is going
to testify regarding how a user may or
may not believe things and how it can be
exported from a celebrated system that's
not new information josh we have turned
over everything in an unprecedented
fashion by way of example when we
receive the search warrant returns
from social media
such as instagram and in facebook on
february the 1st our paralegal who's
been dedicated to this case since
november the 30th every day she's worked
on just this case she's gathering
discovery she's compiling it she's
cataloging it she's redacting it when
necessary she turned that around in one
day so the uh statement that this is
some sort of strategy quite frankly
judges just misses the marketplace
we are following the rules
on the court rules we found all the
rules of discovery we are ready to
proceed today
the information that council just
referenced regarding detective
that's something called call detail
records we've already indicated we're
not going to admit that the exam those
call detail records have been turned
over to defense
now judge we have turned over everything
that we possibly could have we are ready
to proceed today and like i said the
prosecution has been following all the
sport holders thank
you all right the defendants did file an
emergency motion to compel witnessless
door in the alternative to adjourn the
preliminary examination on february 2nd
2022. the quarters had the opportunity
to review the motion the response
also did have a discussion with both
attorneys relative to the nature of the
discovery that had been turned over and
what had not been turned over and or
they believed had not been turned over
the court did allow both
all attorneys to meet prior to beginning
today's hearing for approximately 45
minutes to go over all that discovery in
addition the court adjourned this
preliminary examination for
approximately six weeks because it did
acknowledge and understand that the
discovery in this case would most likely
be voluminous
um having taken all those measures the
court finds that there's sufficient
evidence that has been turned over to
the defense attorneys at this point in
time
that their good cause does not exist to
adjourn the exam again and there is a
good likelihood that this exam will not
complete today and that it may need to
go into another dating time so having
taken all those factors into
consideration the court is going to deny
the motion
um do you think your prosecutor also had
a notion
the people fought the motions well for
strict communications between the
defendants to report it became known to
us that during uh certain zoom breakdown
production for defendants who are making
certain gestures to each other
we're asking support for this court's
inherent authority to restrict the
communication judge i didn't follow
spleen i believe it speaks for itself
yes um your honor the fact that the
prosecution wasn't even aware of the
communications until they were later
told by other people
shows that our clients weren't trying to
do anything to disrupt all of the
communication they didn't realize it was
being broadcasted
um they certainly didn't intend to hurt
any of the victims from oxford um
on that we apologize to the court i
already told the prosecution i would
tell our clients not to have
communications at the table or send
messages if i love you at the table they
agreed there was no reason to file the
motion our clients are will behave
they're not they're not going to do
anything like that and they certainly
don't need to offend anyone thank you
the court has had the opportunity to
review and consider the motion that was
filed by the prosecutor as well as the
oral arguments um i'm going to break the
motion as it relates to import
proceedings mr mrs probably this is a
court proceeding um during the course of
any breaks or while maybe i'm looking
away or somebody else is looking away
you're not to have communication with
each other it's disruptive and it is
disrespectful okay
all right are we ready to begin yeah
i don't believe it's ever been placed on
the record by the defenders that they
understand that they're not they're not
similarly situated they have seen
charges but the evidence will be
different against one that it is against
the other i think it's important to note
it's important for the defendants to
understand that you have accomplished in
that regard
any response from the defense counsel
your honor we acknowledge that the cases
are different for mr crumley versus mrs
crumley and it's part of the reason to
make it easy for this court i'm going to
represent jennifer crumbly and miss
layman's going to represent james for
the purpose throughout this hearing um
i
i don't think this is a concern that
prosecution needs to be raising we're
very aware of the
at least evidence that we believe will
be and i'll just confirm with the
defendants again mr miss is probably
starting with mrs crumley do you
understand that there's potential that
you have different interests and you are
not necessarily on an even uh even par
with each other in terms of what your
issues may be which again could lead to
a potential conflict of interest do you
understand that yeah and knowing that do
you still want to proceed today with
these attorneys yes
mr crumbly do you understand that yes do
you still want to proceed today with
these attorneys yes
go ahead go ahead and call your first
question
i'm sorry we do have two very quick
preliminary vendors first we'd ask the
court to um
have a sequestration order and make that
even more explicit only because there
are witnesses who can view
the court proceedings from outside of
the courtroom with the live streaming so
we would ask that every witness be
instructed there not to view the other
witnesses and for sequestration
okay that's the point with the day of
fault
i believe
um i the witnesses are to my knowledge
all the witnesses have been sequestered
the only witnesses that may be in the
courtroom is the first witness is that
correct i'm going to take a minute and
have the um the prosecutor or the deputy
advise the other witnesses that they are
not to
view
anything on their phones their phone
should be off um
policy from the supreme court is that if
they're in the common areas of the
courthouse they can have their phones
they can have them on in the courtroom
you cannot so i'm going to direct that
they turn their phones off
until after they leave the courthouse
and then you're out of just another
issue which has doesn't have anything to
do with prosecution um in light of some
of the new information that we've been
given this morning myself and my
co-counsel need to
communicate with our clients by writing
notes my client cannot write with the
belly chains can she please have a hand
free and mr crumbly have a hand free so
that they can write back and forth to us
it will allow us to be able to
communicate with them without having to
disrupt their proceedings and stop them
um because we we did receive some
different information than what we've
received uh prior to today's hearing
i've been deferred to the sheriff's
department
you're honored to their their max status
because of their status their maximum
security status i don't feel comfortable
removing the costs from their hands okay
um the problem is
i'm just trying to figure out how we can
uh
she hold the the
pad on her lap
and i will give you a moment in between
if you need to confer with them okay
all right we it might take us
several moments as we go through the
exhibit yeah so you just have everything
on your keep the legal pad on your lap
um and if
you can i know i don't have any any
anything that the table doesn't go over
so it doesn't give you an opportunity to
kind of slide underneath there your
honor is it possible and i guess this
would be a question for the deputies is
it possible just to handcuff them
without the belly change that way
they're still cuffed
no no that wouldn't be possible your
honor if they need to remain in their
what they're brought in
i'm sorry i can't hear you they need to
remain in what they're abroad
okay
all right first witness
uh the prosecution called secure penance
i'm just going to go over a couple of
things with you real quickly
um you can have it screwed up as close
to those microphones as you can
if at any time
you are so comfortable enough and you're
wanting to remove your mask you can do
so
um i also am going to ask you to keep
your voice up so that we can all hear
you
and speak clearly and um make sure you
are verbalizing all the responses don't
shake your head or say uh-huh or i'll
support you can't record that okay okay
okay can you please state your full name
for the record and spell both your first
and last name
my name is
a-i-r-a
e-e-n-n-o-c-k thank you
go ahead council here you may also
remember
[Music]
i run a horse farm
i give lessons in horses
do you own the farm i do okay can you
tell the judge what that entails
um we have some mortgage horses so
people pay us to take care of their
horses
um
we
need horses to water them we turn them
outside
and then we also offer training services
where we
put training on horses or give
riders lessons so how does the business
generate income
um
the
boarding
side of the business covers you know the
expenses of
you know the feed in water the
necessities for the horses and then um
it also covers
the care so we have some workers that
help to
keep business going because we have a
lot of horses
okay without giving the specific address
what town or county where city is the
farm located in memorial
[Music]
do you see them in the courtroom here
today yes could you point to jennifer
crumpley or tell me what something she's
wearing
she is right here in the front she is
wearing a mask and glasses okay
um
notice that the witness is identified as
jennifer
and do you see james coming in the
courtroom here today
no objection you're unloaded
here what do you know about it james or
jennifer
jennifer and where did you meet her
i met her a few years ago um and i met
her through the horse world she
had a horse at the time
was it more than three years ago
i do not believe so okay when you met
her uh did you own your business at the
time no i did not so how did you meet
her
um i have some friends that uh were
familiar with the barn that she had her
horse going to okay at the time that she
had one horse or two one and what was
the name of the horse shorty okay and
currently how many um horses did the
crumb laser do their company's
they have two okay and at some point
another horse was purchased
um yes the second horse was purchased
earlier in 21.
okay and what's the second horse's name
billy and do you know how that purchase
was made and in what
circumstance um
that was an online purchase she had the
horse shipped to michigan and did she
tell you why or how that happened
um she was looking for a new horse that
she could do some jumping on
as shorty had an injury where he could
not be jumping
um so she happened to find this horse
online and uh she purchased it
did she shift over here did she tell you
um how that occurred
um
she
was drinking that night and i said that
she
made a purchase okay how do you know she
was wrong uh she even told me
what exactly did she say did she say she
was intoxicated or she can drink she
said that she was drinking okay and did
she tell you how much the horse cost
she said the horse cost five thousand
dollars all right and you're telling
your testimony as that happened in 2021
yes of what month
was it after you owned the business
no this was at a different boarding
facility okay so do you know about what
month it was purchased
um the horse ended up showing up in
february okay um i'm not sure exactly
when the actual purchase after fell okay
at some point both of the horses were
boarded with you correct yes and when
did that occur
um both horses ended up becoming boarded
with me in
june
to the july time period of 21. okay and
can you tell me what services
if any have you offered james and
jennifer probably with regard
um we have boarded their horses so we
take care of them and then um we were
also giving lessons to both of them and
turning training on their horses okay so
how much per horse does it cost to board
and feed um
per month
um
the
board price for the pasture board that
they were on is
hundred dollars a month four hundred
dollars per month per horse yes okay and
then in addition you said that you were
giving lessons
yes who will be reading lessons too
i was giving lessons to both jennifer
and james um but then ended up
more so just giving lessons to
jennifer as i don't specialize in the
western
right okay and your testimony is you
opened your business in june so what how
many lessons approximately per week was
the goal for jennifer
the goal was about three lessons a week
um how long are those lessons
about 45 minutes to an hour and how much
do they cost they cost 35.
okay and then did james also have
lessons
every week
no he did not take lessons every single
week but um
okay
about how much time let's just narrow it
down from june
until
november
um how many days a week would you see
the front days
i would say they would be out there
about three to four days a week three to
four days a week just during the week or
on the weekend as well
both week and weekends um
usually i would only for them one day on
the weekend
and for about
when they came to see the bar what did
they do and how long did it take
they would groom their horses and tack
them up and ride them
um and then
cool them down and put them away
and that usually took about three hours
okay
did either one of them have jobs at that
time
yes
do you know what they did
i do not know
exactly what job they have do you know
what their hours were i do not what
about what time did they arrive in
during the day
they would usually come around five
o'clock on the weekdays and then
weekends they
would usually come around like between
nine and eleven in the morning did they
for the most part come together
yes okay
did their son ever come with them
i have not seen their son at my bond
okay
have you ever seen it
i have seen him maybe once or twice
and that would be the previous one yes
okay
so you're saying so
three to four times a week
probably around five o'clock about three
hours yes okay
did the horses ever require any
care
other than just boarding and feeding and
grooming
um yes sometimes we've had to put um
like ointments or take care of them if
they injure themselves or need some type
of fat care okay um along with uh
holding down for the barrier
okay
for those of us in the world that aren't
exactly sure what a barrier is can you
tell the court what that is
basically a person that does a pedicure
for horse they can put shoes on a horse
um and they just make sure the horse
stays uh
sound enough for either riding or
pasture even if a horse can't be
brimming um and that's a regular service
that needs to be done how how often does
it need to be
um every six to eight weeks and did the
promptly uh provide that to their horses
um for their horses it was about 130
each course okay and then if the course
needed uh assistance because it was
injured or sick whose responsibility is
it to get veterinary care
it is the owner's responsibility to
pay for the care um
from the vet and
um also most of the like if it's very
involved here they should be the ones
doing it but we do offer
the services of you know
putting appointment on a horse's moves
uh that's just and so for the most part
did they did james and jennifer make
sure that was done
i would say so yes okay i guess you
before if you've ever seen your stun
since you started your business and you
said
i have not
seen him more than maybe once or twice
okay do you know why he didn't come to
the barn with his parents for three
hours three to four times a week i was
told that he didn't really
want anything to do with the horses who
told you that
jen
would you
consider
jennifer a friend
i would okay and at some point
did you ever become aware of any marital
issues
she has mentioned some things in the
past
[Music]
your honor
according to mre 201 and people versus
mills which is the michigan supreme
court in 1995 case evidence is relevant
if it's a material or program it issue
here is defendant's duty to protect the
community from intentionally harming
someone by willful disregarding of clear
signs of danger what they did what they
didn't do how they spent their time what
they exposed their son to all is
probative and material and i believe it
is relevant
the court is going to overwhelm the
objections go ahead
um
she had mentioned that um
she had found some information of uh
she thought that james was cheating on
her
singles in
uh the area online um but then ethan had
one moment
okay so
summer 2021 i would say so yes okay and
what was her reaction to that
she was very upset and did she tell you
what she did
as a result
she confronted
james about it
and james had said that he didn't do
that
um and then even had come forward and
said that he was the one that was
looking keith up online
okay so did she tell you that then even
was aware of this accusation of dancing
um i do not recall if she
said that he knew about it okay uh what
was your general impression of jennifer
i
did not have any issues with her i
i just graduated i really like how
dedicated she was to the horses
um and she
had aspirations of doing some
competitions in the summer
during show season um
and
she had always treated me and everybody
else with respect to her
okay and
did she talk about her slander
not a whole lot
did she ever talk about anything
positive about herself
i don't recall her
outright saying anything super positive
um
did she ever express um anything
concerning
yes what did she say
she said that
he did not have any friends
that he only had one friend and
he spent a lot of time
online for playing games
but he just seemed to keep to himself
did she have a word to describe that
um
not really
she thought that it was weird that he
wasn't out doing things like a normal
kid did she come here
what did you say did she call him weird
yes okay
and
was there
a time do you remember the time frame
she told you that he didn't have any
friends
i do not remember the sign okay
did she consider him a normal
no
have you known
um
just
how she
really didn't talk a lot about them and
when she would talk about it if it was
just
you know oh
he doesn't do normal good things okay
did you have any contact with jennifer
or james
uh
on november 30 yeah 2021
do you did either one of them to your
knowledge go to the barn on that day
uh james had gone that warning to put
some ointment out of billy's legs
what what was wrong with with billy's
legs billy has something called um
mud fever or scratches it's a fungus
that
sometimes will grow unworthy and it
causes scabs and it's pretty painful and
did the problem seem concerned about the
laces of flex
yes okay and how do you know james was
there did you see him i did not see him
um but
some of the other people in my arm saw
him there
okay
did you have a conversation at all
either
on a phone or via text with jennifer
about
um anything on that day yes okay and
when you say you know james was there
was was he there in the early morning in
the afternoon do you have any idea what
time
i do not know exactly when i just know
that it was in the morning
because you saw that the sam was on
philly's legs yes and what time did you
notice that
um that was probably a wrong name
okay
uh
so did you ever see jennifer that day
i did not okay but she spoke to you what
did you do text her or call her
uh facebook messenger okay and did you
often communicate with her through
facebook messenger yes
is that something you use normally is
there a reason why versus text um it
seems to be a lot easier for people to
just message through facebook
um
i'm not totally
here i'm approaching with an exhibit
people propose sixth of it there's
approximately 28 pages
and can you tell the court what that is
um these are the messages
um
that morning
of uh november 30th
and who are they messages
between uh between myself and jennifer
and that's facebook messenger yes okay
can you tell the court when the messages
start and when they end
the messages start at
10 18 am on november 30th
and
the messages end
um
and not really sure date wise
when they
they end here um there is no date on
these but i know that you can take a
look at the last couple pages the last
date that you see
um
it just says
to you but where did those come from do
you know
um these
messages they came from my phone okay
how did they get to
to the sheriff's part
um i had sent screenshots of my messages
because they asked you to correct yeah
okay um
was jennifer
did jennifer have a lesson planned that
tuesday november 30th yes
and what time was it supposed to be um
well initially it was supposed to be
around
like 4 30
and then um
we
had had to push it even she said that
she couldn't okay we'll guess that um so
aside from the lesson there was also
a really a big concern about billy's
legs and what did you call that paper
yes okay would you
would you rate the concern of the
crumblies
pretty high about much people is that
something really serious that a horse
can get it is not super serious but it's
definitely something that needs to take
care of uh needs to be taken care of but
um with billy's legs it was just unusual
for his legs to
swell up it became swollen um and i was
all over legs when the blood paper was
only on two of them so that was a little
concerning okay
um i'm going to event proposed uh
people's protocols exhibit six i believe
defense counsels had a chance to look it
over and does not have an objection no
objection judge all right may publish
yes
may have published um
and can you read
is that are your comments in black or
are they in blue
uh my comments are in blue okay so we
say it says november 30th at 10 18. can
you read that first text message that
you sent that day
uh
boys are needing supplements for tonight
and shorty locks development again okay
and then at 10 58 there was a response
from jennifer and can you read what she
responded hey i'll bring some out later
just had to go to my son's school and
meet his counselor
did you know what that was about
i did not know
then what that was about okay what
what did you
based on her describing it as shit day
what was your impression
um that something probably happened that
what uh what did you respond at 11 13
kira um
i responded with oh man everything okay
you still want to do a lesson tonight
and her response
yeah i still plan on doing the lesson
everything's okay he's just having a
hard time after losing tank his friend
going away to a treatment facility and
who knows what else but he was taught to
run this
assignment today okay who's tank do you
know uh tank was their dog okay and did
you know about the loss of the dog
recently and the friend leaving your one
party head leaving yes okay and then she
texts you um a picture of a what looks
like a a man worksheet correct yes okay
did you look at it closely again
i
looked at it after i happened to open it
and see it that day and what was your
response to that
um well my
my response uh wait i didn't ask that
girl what
what did you personally what was
personally your response to it what did
you get i was alarmed i thought that was
not normal
what was alarming to you about it
um
all of the violence
all over the page um
it just didn't really seem like
something
that um
a kid would do on a
test in school okay were you aware that
the companies owned guns yes were you
aware that they purchased a gun to their
son
i did not know the governor's order son
do you follow her on social media i do
did you view a post about taking her son
to
mother sunday and a early christmas
present do you see that post i have seen
it but i'm not sure exactly when um
i don't really spend a lot of time on
social media okay me
okay uh so you
you're you said you were 24 correct 25
25 i'm sorry and you you're not a parent
no but you were really alarmed about
that yes okay and what happened after
she tested you what was the next text
that came through
um
the next
the text was uh as long as i can get out
there early enough so this is from
jennifer yes okay can you speak up just
a little bit and read that yes um as
long as i can get out there early enough
because i had to leave work for an hour
and i have a meeting in south field at
three o'clock but i should be done with
that by four i plan
being there plus the vet said it's
better for him to move around and keep
it circulating
um
while he's uh dealing with them on fever
good times good times okay so and do you
understand based on the text messages
that she'd already met with the school
yes okay and she's texting you about mud
fever now yes all right what was the
next textbook
um i said omg
he needs some horse therapy i bet he
would love him and who were you talking
about who's he um
okay and then what did you say after
that dad whatever works for you just let
me know i only have bella's lesson
tonight at 5 30 so anytime after her
lesson is fine
okay what was the response
okay yeah well he'll be coming out with
me tonight james is working he can't be
left alone
so he can't be left alone
who did you understand her to be talking
about
i
about
understand
and you stated one
i said that or does he want to ride
in her response
and she said i don't know maybe brush a
small horse so he's not
intimidated lol
and you're suggesting mo
yes who i assume is the horse you own
i do not own him he was ordered at our
facility all right and your suggestion
was
what um make it a family event coming
out to the barn really though i've seen
some amazing things done with horses
with kids
and what did jennifer say
uh he needs something
and then what
um i
said let's make him a cowboy
and jen has responded lol mango goals
for real
all right here you know what happened on
november 30th
yes when did you hear about it
i heard about it um when i got a call
from one of my students moms about what
time was that that was in the early
afternoon
do you know people
and kids that were in that school that
day i do how many
um i know
one for sure um one of my students
and um i know some of
the other kids not personally but that
were
in the school also okay when you heard
about the shooting
did
was it public who was responsible for it
it was not what was your thought in
media
my thought was that it was even and tell
me why you thought it was immediate your
immediate thought was anything
because i know that they own guns and i
know that they go out shooting
you hear again from jennifer that day
what was the time
um
what was the next oh um
here i won't be there tonight and that
came in at 2 36 in the afternoon yes
and she says what
yes please
and then it looks like the next uh
communication was from you at 2 58 and
you stated what i just brought in
now you're texting her a photo i assume
that's billy yes
did you text photos back and forth about
the worst frequently
um
sometimes i would say that most of our
conversations are related to the horses
okay and you don't hear anything back
until what time
um i don't hear anything back
from her
until uh tuesday
at 4 42 and she had responded
okay so you
that day asked her everything was okay i
heard there was a shooting in oxford is
ethan okay and then you again respond
reach out at 421 correct
yes and you don't respect your back
until
from her until
tuesday at 4 42. so the same day and
she's saying i need to sell my horse's
death yeah okay did she go on to talk
about how much why she needs to sell her
horses no okay eventually did you
continue working this out with the does
she want does she want you to help her
sell the horses yes okay did you do that
i am still currently trying to help sell
them
just so that we know there's two
versions of that sheet so i want to make
sure
the conversations that occurred
afterwards um
we're
you seemed compassionate compassionate
for jennifer
at the beginning right yes okay
i wanted more information
on
what happened
okay and
um
you've stated a couple times in the in
the um exhibit the conversations just be
honest
yes what did you mean by that
i
wanted her to be honest about
anything and everything um i
i'm a very truthful person
and um
i think that the truth
is much better than a lie okay did you
suspect what was the reason you
suspected that you might not be asked
was there something that you were
concerned about your honor i would
object that this calls for um
speculation and also the question is
presuming facts that were not not
in evidence prior to the question
i'm not i'm not exactly sure what the
objection is but i can move on uh so
at some point um
did you
stop communicating with her
um
i tried to still talk to her but i the
conversations got
fewer and far between
did jennifer ever mention
taking ethan to the doctor no
did she ever talk about him needing to
get a physical or
he was ill and needed treatment i don't
think
did james ever talk about that no okay
and did you ever hear either one of them
talk about getting their son there
no
come on
just just real quick here
i i understand that your um your farm is
further more
um what's the cell coverage like there
um
it is better than a lot of other farms
but
there are still areas where you don't
really get
yes and how about text messages yes okay
and did the fronties both have cell
phones with them most of the time do you
know yes
thank you
um
what type of cell coverage do you have
um i have uh verizon which seems to be
pretty good in that area
is it fair to say that you don't know
what other cell phones like companies
how good nexus is
i do not know
are there parts of the farm where people
complain they can't get messages or talk
on the phone
um
some areas you can
get some people get serviced and then
other areas
sorry i interrupted you how big is the
farm
uh the farm is on 51 acres
and in addition to the farm
um there's a separate place where you do
where you do classes is that correct
or what is groveland
was the barn that we had previously
boarded at i ordered my horses there and
jenna had her horses there is brooklyn
where you met jen
no i met her at the previous farm before
that okay so you guys were the previous
term before then you were both at
groveland and then uh jen went on to
board her horses at your current farm i
never boarded my horses at the first
barn that i met her at that was just
where you met her yes okay
and
um you said you believe you two met in
about 2019 is that correct
i believe it was earlier than that but i
can't
it's fair to say that horses in training
and what's going on with the horses at
the barn
that's
the majority of what you and jennifer
talk about is that correct yes um
jennifer does not
talk to you about when she goes to the
doctor herself
no jennifer doesn't tell you about
james's doctor's appointments no
um jennifer
never gave you much detail about the
names of the people she worked with or
what she did at work
no
um jennifer
did jennifer ever give you details about
james like who he worked with things he
did
not a whole lot of detail i just know
that she had said that he has been
through a few different trials okay
and as far as ethan goes um
[Music]
your testimony was you have not seen him
at the barn did you ever see ethan when
he would go to groveland
i may have seen him once or twice when
they were just dropping something off it
was always a quick visit i don't know if
i've ever actually
talked to him
in
and it's fair to say that you talked to
jen more about horses
than ethan is that correct yes
and
um
and with respect to ethan coming um you
wouldn't have had a problem if ethan
came that day on november 30th is that
correct
i would not have had an issue with them
coming
um it would have been unusual for ethan
to come to the barn with jen on the 30th
um because he didn't normally go with
her is that correct all right
and
on the 30th when she was planning to
bring ethan um
you assumed she was
um upset about ethan or had
some kind of concern for ethan is that
correct
yes jen also had the option to save you
i'm canceling the lesson i'm not gonna
come i won't be there correct yes and in
her messages to you
um it was clear to you that she did not
want ethan to be alone is that correct
yes
did jennifer talk to you about
um some of the comments on the math
paperwork such as like my life is
useless
um
or the thoughts won't stop did jennifer
speak to you about any of the individual
comments
no she had just sent me the picture
um did you
were you concerned that ethan may be
suicidal after seeing these notes
yes
um prior to
the 30th when you saw this math note had
you ever been concerned that ethan would
be suicidal
no had you ever had reason to believe he
was homicidal or he would hurt other
people
no have you ever been given reason to
believe
um he was not mentally
sound that he needed
professional you know
medical help no
in terms of your friendship with
jennifer
[Music]
it's fair to say when she's texting you
and she says something like lol
you understand what what she means by
those comments correct yes
so for example when she
uh sends a text about you send a text
about let's make ethan a cowboy is that
correct yes and she texts back mom goals
uh something along those lines correct
yes um you know that jennifer is
is kidding around and sarcastic almost
is that correct
i don't know how this witness can tell
what's in the mind of jennifer
i'll be asked a question
um did you perceive her response as
as um serious that that was a model for
her to make ethan a cowboy
um i could see her wanting to
um
be able to have her son out at the bar
and go riding a lot of parents want to
do something with their their kids and
um
that that was how i took it but um a lot
of boys don't really like to ride horses
so i didn't see it as a serious
thing that would actually happen
okay you it's fair to say that you and
jennifer are able to kid back and forth
though correct yes
um with you testified that you don't see
as many boys do you see more girls
coming out to the barn for writing yes
um how many more what percentage would
you say if you were talking about young
people like teenagers are girls versus
boys
um well we currently do not have any
boys coming out to drive
really i mean um one of the other
people i've already has
a younger male student but um outside of
that there are no other boys
approximately how many girls are out of
the barn on any given day
um i would say
between
each day two to four each day
and really no boys is that correct yes
um when people come out to the barn is
it pretty typical if they have horses
there for them to be out there
about three to four times per week for
three hours each time
it depends on each person's situation
some people will see once a week some
people will see every single day
okay so there's nothing unusual
about three to four times a week for
three hours at a time
correct
and um
it's not something that you thought was
unusual to not see ethan coming with his
mother
um out of the barn correct
you certainly don't follow up with other
people who have sons that aren't present
out at the horse at the farm correct
um in the text messages with ethan uh
i'm sorry you said they were facebook
messenger messages
yes facebook messages with jennifer um
jennifer and you
go on the whole exhibit has been
admitted so the whole packet is admitted
um it's fair to say that beyond what the
prosecution showed after those messages
you and jennifer communicated
about you buying billy
um
is that correct
yes i was planning to buy both billy and
jordy and you talked about buying billy
shorty's attack other horse plane
related items yes
okay and you um we're talking to
jennifer about how the horses could be
signed over or what you guys would need
to do is that correct yes
and
in addition to
the comments about the horses
it's fair to say that throughout the
texts you could tell jennifer was upset
yes
so
for example when she said i'm balling
right now kira
um
how did you take that what did you take
that to me
she was upset and she really loved her
horses
and
when he when jennifer wrote my my son
ruined so many lives today what did you
take
and um
you reassured her that you're gonna
you'll take care of the horse and for
her to take something off her plate
correct yes
and um
you reassured her in terms of saying try
to get some rest you'll need it that
kind of thing yes
um jennifer thanked you for not judging
her unlike the rest of the world
how did you take that
i
didn't really know how to take
that um you did text
jennifer
i know you and james correct yes and you
texted
this doesn't even remotely make me think
it's your fault
is that a message you sent john yes
it sounds like ethan was a troubled kid
is that correct when you said
this doesn't even remotely make me think
it's your fault what did you mean by
that
i had never gotten the feeling that um
jen and james
had those types of issues with their son
so although you knew a limited amount
about ethan because ethan wasn't someone
you frequently talked about
you never had the idea that
something like the tragedy that happened
on 11 30 could happen and ethan could be
responsible for it correct
you also tried to reassure her try to
stay calm and as collected as you can
um those were some messages you sent in
addition to a message that said just be
honest about everything correct yes
um who had written billy that day he was
going to be fine helping
alleviate stress on that and for judd is
that correct yes
um when jennifer texted you and said i
wish we had warnings something
he's a good kid
they made a terrible decision
how did you
what did you think after getting that
text
i was thinking there had to have been
some type of science um she had
mentioned in the past like you know that
he really didn't have friends he didn't
go out and do
fun things like
um kids his age
um so i
well
the text is from
her to you saying i wish we had warnings
something
he's a good kid
they made a terrible decision
um you didn't point out to her things
that you thought may have been signs in
the past correct correct
um
you actually wrote there probably were
warnings but nobody saw them correct
yes and you said hindsight is always 20
20.
yes
and we can all agree looking back
um
when something bad happens we look back
at what could have prevented it correct
yes
[Music]
when
jennifer said he's a good kid you didn't
write back to her anything like well
actually your son is not a good kid
correct correct
and although he didn't hang out with
friends um you were aware that he had
one friend who's particularly close to
correct yes
and
um on facebook
throughout jen's profile you said you
were a social media contact with her is
that correct yes you can you can see
could you see pictures of them going
camping and taking even places
i did see posts about them doing things
with them so there were posts about the
family spending time together camping um
going places on the weekend correct yes
and
um
you testified you understood he played a
lot of video games is that correct yes
and that never struck you as something
that was overly problematic correct
no
um you had no reason to ever say to jen
like hey john wake up there are signs or
anything like that
after um
you were aware that ethan
had been the shooter
um
you and jennifer um attempted to
talk to each other on the phone do you
recall that yes
and
do you recall that jennifer said you had
to call her through facebook
um
because she has to use a track phone yes
at that point did you and jennifer have
a telephone conversation
he did not
okay so in the facebook messenger thread
when it says like you missed a call from
jc i assume jc is jennifer crumley yes
and then it says um call me back on
facebook i'm on a track phone i need to
talk and figure some things out you and
jennifer didn't have any phone contact
at that point
we did not
and when jennifer was on that track
phone she said it would be easier
because texting on that phone is hard if
you guys could talk correct yes
um
further down you
you continue to let her know that billy
was fine had a good ride with him
correct yes
and
at that point you became concerned about
jennifer
coming out to the farm is that correct
yes why were you concerned with jennifer
coming to the farm
because i did not want them to
um
take
things
um that were owned by other borders or
myself
you didn't want jennifer to take things
that were owned by other borders or
yourself
correct
did you um
were you concerned about the safety of
people at the farm if jennifer and james
showed up
yes
were you concerned because jennifer
showed you some of the
threatening messages she had received
yes
and when you explained to jennifer you
were concerned and wanted the police to
be out there
you actually wrote i don't want people
to follow you or hurt you correct yes
and you said we just need to be careful
yes
so nothing about
any horse equipment or concerns
um and were you afraid that people
were going to follow the crumblings out
to the farm and possibly hurt people i
was worried about that
after that
um discussion about the police mrs
probably made it
clear that they were headed to a safe
place for a couple days is that correct
yes they did not tell you she did not
say the location they were going to just
a safe place yes she has said that it's
a hotel or hotel in here
and that was i don't know where exactly
they've gone and then your messages to
her where i'm very glad you're safe i
care about you guys correct yes was that
true yes
and again you reassure her i will take
care of your boys let me know when you
want me to buy them and i'll buy them if
you were trying to figure out something
to see if you could buy them is that
right yes
you also said if you need anything just
let me know correct yes
doing all the things that you could do
as a friend to jennifer
yes and i also want to make sure that
her horses didn't end up in a bad
situation
and jennifer wanted to make sure the
horses didn't end up in a bad situation
too as far as you can tell yes
and as you're texting her about the
horses and everything else um
in the little bit about what's going on
after finding out about the shooting
you didn't follow up with her about what
her work arrangements were
no you didn't follow up with her about
what if james was still working or what
he was doing
no
you didn't follow up with her about any
other kind of personal issues related to
her
all that you followed up about is what
we can see in the tests yes
so it's fair to say that your friendship
with jennifer was pretty limited to
horses care for horses and maybe just
some friendly chitchat correct yes
looking back you're not looking at
conversations regarding ethan
as anything where you should have
contacted law enforcement correct all
right nothing where you should have had
an alarm block and say oh i should call
the police about this one
correct even the day that you saw the
drawing that's up on the board
um
you didn't contact law enforcement to
say i just saw like a really crazy
drawing or anything along those lines i
did not and if anything um jennifer
appeared to be very concerned about what
was going on correct
yes
when jennifer um
had ever been out to the school or not
you weren't aware of every time jennifer
had ever been over to oxford high is
that fair to say
correct
so that day um stuck out as something
unusual
yes
um you guys were attempting to put
together um cash
that
that you were potentially going to pay
her for horses is that correct yes
ultimately the two of you never
physically met up is that correct
so the extent of all of your
communications is contained within these
28 pages of facebook messenger messages
yes you already testified there were no
phone calls and there was no personal
like one-on-one contact yes
i just need my name
i have nothing further on behalf of
jennifer crumbly any questions that we
have james cumberland yes thank you
did i pronounce that correctly
yes thank you um you testified that you
didn't speak to james very often did you
yes
that's correct you did not speak him
and when you did it was about the forces
is that fair yes force-related matters
correct yes um he didn't tell you that
he had to go to the doctor or anything
right no he didn't tell you that jen had
been to the doctor no he didn't talk
about ethan's medical appointments no so
similar to jen he kept his
communications with you about forces and
force-related matters is that fair yes
and you didn't reach out to
james after seeing this picture from jen
and say i'm really concerned about ethan
right i did not and you testified
previously that
your communications with jen or or
james
you never were
you never were concerned about ethan is
that fair
correct
there were there was never anything that
you saw that gave you cause to be
concerned about ethan's mental health
right
no
and when again when you did talk to
james
it was limited to
horses and related matters yes so it
wasn't strange
that he didn't talk about
work right
or doctor's appointments
yeah or ethan
his relationship with you was because of
the horses yes
nothing further judge thank you can you
redraft
kept your conversations to friendly
chit-chat is that right
yes except that she did talk to you
about her husband having you here
yes and she did talk to you about the
fact that he only had one friend
yes and she did talk to you about how he
didn't like horses yes okay and in all
the time that you've met jennifer and
jason you've known them how many times
have you seen either
maybe once or twice okay let me ask you
this did both parents have to go to the
barn every time for three to four times
a week three hours at a time
they did not have to go together fair to
say
some of that stuff all of that stuff
could have been done by one person
yes okay and
when you told ms smith that um jennifer
was very concerned um she still did
though have the time to text you about
billy's mud fever
and
arrange the lesson and then cancel the
lesson yes okay and when you said you
told her it's not your fault and you you
know time size 2020 at that time that
you stated that did you know that um
that they purchased a gun for ethan and
it was accessible to him i did not know
that the gun was or
accepted objection your honor about
accessible that was they're not offering
it to prove that
it wasn't
sustaining the objection the first
question thank you did you did you know
that jennifer texted ethan the day
before um about the ammunition search
hello well you have to learn not to get
caught i did not know did you know that
uh
that the school
told jennifer and james they needed to
get in therapy i did not know did you
know that when they heard about a
shooting that james went home to look to
see if that gun was there i did not did
you know he called
and did you 911 that jennifer texted
don't do it you don't do it i did not
know that either
um
yes
any objection
no judge thank you none from mr crumbler
let's keep
what's up
because the screenshots
it's very important for you to respond
to all questions verbally um please
refrain from that in your head and
saying aha
because it's difficult for the full
reporter to record additionally you can
keep your voice up so everybody can hear
you that would be helpful um i will
leave it up to you as to whether or not
you're comfortable removing your mask
you want to remove your nest
so you may as you can see we do have
lots of glass around the witness stand
and
keep it on okay
and then you do need to keep your voice
up there okay okay if you could please
state and spell what's your first and
last name for the right andrew smith
[Music]
and can you tell me what your um
position is now
i work as chief operations officer for
real estate company
okay and what are your duties
manage the operations
of the counseling
and how many employees are in the
company
approximately 700. all right do you know
jennifer crumley yes
all right do you see jennifer probably
in the courtroom yes
describe
when did uh jennifer probably begin
working for the
were you her direct supervisor
i was
most recently but now when she was hired
okay so for how long you her supervisor
how many years ago
all right and what were her
responsibilities
she was a marketing director
she was a marketing director for the
company okay as a marketing director
what what does that entail what what
kinds of mediums or um services does she
oversee responsible for marketing the
property the asset responsible for
social media
for reviews ratings
um online reviews website related
materials
working with third-party vendors
working with the properties on their
internal external marketing portfolio
yes we have a large social media
platform instagram
i believe so yes yes facebook yes
twitter
don't think so okay
um
so
what were jennifer crumley's
hours work hours
standard uh 40 hours a week i think she
came in eight o'clock
or before leave around four o'clock
was that the same every day
i believe so for the most part yes and
in your company do employees have to
choose which hours they work and work
the same time a day or is it flexible
it's so much flexible
we want a 40-hour
and do you allow employees to work from
home
we have when needed yes is jennifer prom
gave a working one i believe so at times
yes
would you describe your company as
family family yes very much
i think we're very family friendly if
there's ever a need or a time for a
family issue it's always been granted
okay
um
taking you to back to november 30th uh
do you remember that day i do and do you
remember having any contact with
jennifer franklin
i do
can you tell the court what was your
first nonsense
i received a text message from miss
crumley that morning about 10 a.m was it
a text or a facebook messenger a text
message
is that how you normally communicated
with her
in person by email or by phone
text or facebook messenger oh text
message yes yes
about approximately what time was that
and i believe there's a stipulation to
it
okay bro yes and that's crochet
okay mr smith what what are you looking
at what did i just handle you handed me
and you were aware at the time i was
driving my vehicle okay did you
um get a good look at the text
i saw that you talked to me while
driving that she was going through a
child's school council okay was that
something that she's required to do she
leaves work
you're supposed like your supervisor
will know if you're going into the new
markets okay
and um did you respond no
all right publish the exhibit
okay so
the
the worksheet which has also previously
been exhibited um entered into evidence
she also attached the the math worksheet
correct correct yes
all right and what exactly do you read
the test that she sent
i have to go to my kids school counselor
just called and this is what i'm dealing
with i'll be back by 11 30 12 at the
latest
and then
what was the next communication you had
with jennifer public i believe i
saw her at work around you in that day
did you take a good look at that
worksheet
okay so you said you saw her later at
work do you know what time that was just
passed me 12 now okay and who are you
here
um i saw in the copy room in our office
in just a step
did she talk about anything um that she
did outside of work
very little she talked about her horses
and she owned horses and she would enjoy
horses
maybe vacation or there a little travel
but not a lot okay
uh so
the next time you saw jennifer i'm sorry
you said
it was around 12 p.m
okay and what was the did you have a
conversation with her yes and what was
the
conversation about a asked her how
things were how she was doing and she
had that
she her son needed to get some
counseling
and
then she mentioned his
dog
family had it passed away and a
grandparent had passed away recently and
she felt like she was failing to kill
him
i'm sorry she said what i think she said
she
felt like she was failing him or a
failure
all right when she said she had to get
counseling did she say why no oh she
said she didn't say why she just
mentioned that family pettit passed away
a
grandparent had passed away
and but she didn't say
why did she tell you um what the
situation was at school
no just that she was told she needed to
get some constant personality okay and
her son was not going through friends
no
okay by the way you do a lot of kids
come to your workplace right this
happened yeah
um
can you tell the court
what was on
jennifer crumbley's
schedule that day
i know we had a meeting scheduled to
visit a coffee that afternoon and and
did you talk to her about going to the
meeting
yes when did you speak with her
he may have talked before the 30th where
we talked that day that afternoon where
did you have that conversation
shortly after we talked
in the coffee room so maybe 20 minutes
half hour later heard another colleague
and i had a brief conversation about a
property visit that afternoon
and about
and was she required to go to that
meeting
she was invited not required did you
tell her
no did you tell her
at that meeting i mentioned to her she
was her
choice i did say that yes okay and if
she had not returned
to work that afternoon
what would have happened to jennifer
crumbly at her workplace
i'm confused
what is the uh protocol if somebody has
to leave for an issue with their child
or something else we have a pto policy
but when it comes to what is pto
paid time off okay um which you would
submit your time on an online portal but
if you had a family issue you would
always be granted time for a family
whatever maybe
okay and did she ever request to leave
that day
um after she went to school and came out
she never requested but she did leave
that day yes okay
um
what was the next time
that you spoke to
jennifer after
uh you had a meeting about
um
the next time i spoke to was briefly
when i heard her screaming
down the hallway how far away is your
officer's nurse
10 feet
okay and what you said you heard
screaming
yeah i heard some loud yelling screaming
what did you do
i heard it i was i think i was on a
caller's zoom and i
walked out of my office to see what was
going on
and i saw her miss from these mrs from
would say that there was an active
shooter in child school and she had to
go and did she leave she did and i
assume you didn't have a problem with
that yes
okay well did you hear from her again
yes
uh can you tell where
what how did you hear the text to call i
received both she attacked me
do you know what time those occurred
i received a text message about 20-30
minutes after she laughed okay let's um
we have the exhibit published
and can you read that text that came in
1 23 p.m correct okay do you know if you
know how long after
uh how long it was from the time she
left to the time she sent that test i
think 20 30 minutes okay can you read
the text
the gun is gone and saw the bullets
okay
what
can she text the gun is gone so were the
bullets
did you know anything about about the
gun at this point
okay and what happened after that
i texted her back i said i'm praying
everything was okay i didn't know what
to say
did you know that there was a gun or
bullets in the home at all not them were
no yeah what not that i was aware of no
okay so had you had a previous
conversation done for crumbly about guns
none
did you ever remember seeing a post
about that
i remember seeing the post by shooting
before the 30th i don't recall before
after i don't i don't know okay and
what did she respond
what did the phone call the first phone
call
it was about 1 30 1 25 and 30. so was it
before the next test
i
yes i believe it was yes
[Music]
text i i was actually in a hearing on a
zoo meeting
and i stepped away because i was
concerned about what i had just received
and learned
walked down to our hr director's office
in her office i received a phone call
and did you have the phone on speaker or
did you just call anywhere i took the
comment on speaker okay and what did
jennifer say
i recall her saying she was trying to
get to her child's school
she saw her frantic either ambulance or
sirens in the background
and that
the gun was missing
when she said
how did she describe the gun
door closed after just there's a gun
missing that they're done
okay and
what did you say about anything
kath and i both told her you need to
call the police
and what did she say
she said that my husband is at home and
already calls
okay and then did the call line right
then or was there more competition i
don't recall more i think it ended
shortly after we might have said you
know please let us know if you need
anything but i don't call exactly
okay
and
um
after that then you receive the next
test
yes yes i believe so and what does it
say
omg andy he's going to kill himself he
must be the shooter
and then the next cast i need a lawyer
with police
and then what else ethan did it
okay what
what was your response at this point
complete shock
and what what did you do
i i was i loved hr dr know the time um
we didn't really know what to do we were
looking for the story online to see if
everyone was okay did you know what was
going on we were really concerned
greatly concerned in shock
did she
make another phone call to you yes do
you know what that occurred
[Music]
okay so there
there was a
what was the 215 call about
who was the president i was again i was
in our hr director's office i put on
speaker and
she had said she saw her son at the
police station
her caller is saying that and i call her
saying that she asked if i could refer
to a recommended lawyer what did you say
at the time
i was
completely in shock and overwhelmed but
we were learning to think of anyone that
would a millionaires be able to suggest
was that okay i didn't even know what
where to start okay and then the next
time you hear from jennifer from
i received a text at 3 39 p.m
okay and what does the text say
i need my job please don't judge me for
what my son did
and what did you think about that
i was
surprised by that test why is that
i was surprised she was worried about
her job at the time i thought she'd be
more worried about what was going on
and at that point was it when it was
colored
yes we learned there was a shooting we
were supposed to find out more but we've
learned that there was an active
shooting axe
just for clarification i know that this
exhibit was stipulated too i just wanted
the
recorded pursuit
probably
mr smith at some point that meeting you
spoke of that um this is probably
would you consider it optional that she
hugged me
yeah she was invited she did not have
two times did it actually take place no
why didn't that take place
but what happened that day was the last
thing you were worried about was going
to visit
thank you
good afternoon
my name is shannon smith i am a lawyer
representing jennifer crumley um
if i ask any confusing questions please
let me know okay
um
you testified that the is family
friendly correct correct if people need
time off to do things for their children
um your company's flexible and allows
that to happen yes
and um
[Music]
in terms of with uh jennifer crumley you
were aware ethan was her son yes
and while you didn't discuss ethan very
often um she
she didn't make it any secret she had
ethan as her son correct i knew
did you see that she had photographs of
him playing soccer up in her office
it sounds familiar yes
and most of what you and jennifer talk
about in the grand scheme of things is
work related uh issues correct yes would
you describe jennifer as being somebody
who's very conscientious about her work
yes and would you agree with me that
she's a definite go-getter wanting to
get promotions wanting to make more
money wanting to get further ahead
she was definitely professional and very
good she was better job and handled
herself very well yes the position that
she was in at the on november 30th
that position i think you said was
director of marketing is that correct
right
and the director role was actually a
newer role for jennifer
um
is that correct
yes i believe she had been in that
position about a year and a half okay so
prior to her being in that position she
was in a lower position and she had
worked up to being the director
yes
um and it's fair to say jennifer
appears to be a hard worker
i believe so yes
and um
[Music]
okay so
you were you've been in touch with her
um and working with her the entire time
she's been employed at the company
correct
she didn't report to me until she became
the director of marketing but we looked
at that interaction before that contrast
all right thank you
when um you were talking to jennifer and
um she mentioned she had to go over to
the school counselor
um you testified that she said something
about i feel like a failure is that
correct yes how what did you take that
to me
i didn't know i didn't know i think she
just felt sad about the situation
um did she seem um nervous or upset
anything like that
she seems somewhat down
okay
so she left work and she went over to
the school
um
and i believe the text
or you unders did she tell you she was
going to the school or was it just the
text that i have to go to my kid's
school
and
have their
was it frequent that you would get texts
from her that she had to go to the
school to see the counselor
i don't recall any other tax regarding a
counselor
was there ever um other times that were
there
other times where jennifer had to go
over and meet with people at the school
as far as you know i don't know
um it's fair to say that jennifer having
to go over to the school that wasn't
something that consistently disrupted
work
not bad
so you testified she went over the
school and then did you say there was a
phone call after she left the school
or what was what was the next phone call
i received a phone call from her that
afternoon
okay and that afternoon the phone call
you described her as being frantic
yes okay tell me what you mean by that
she seemed very alarmed and concerned
did she seem upset
she seemed very alarmed certainly i
guess you could say upset yes but it was
more that she was in a frantic concern
and was that when she was it was your
understanding she was trying to get to
the child's school
yes
um and it was in that phone call where
she told you that there was a gun and
that
james had already called the police
about the gun is that correct correct
at that point in time um
did you and jennifer discuss any other
issues
not that i recall okay was it a
a conversation that was
frantic in terms of fast paced or was it
was it slower paced
do you recall how that call was i just
recall she was frantic and utah very
alarmed okay and obviously that
concerned you
absolutely
when um
when you received the text
uh that said oh my god andy he's going
to kill himself he must be the shooter
um
[Music]
what did you take that text to mean
i don't know how the answer i was very
alarmed by this stuff
ethan
um
being suicidal was that something that
you had ever discussed with jennifer
crumbly no
ethan um
being a shooter of any person or
being thought to be
homicidal was that something you had
ever discussed with jennifer no
head had you ever had thoughts in your
mind that
based on what jennifer said in front of
you that ethan
would be a school shooter
no
as far as you are aware um jennifer is
the breadwinner in the home is that a
fair statement
i don't know
you so you don't discuss the details of
jane's employment or what james does
with him
i've never discussed anything with james
before now
okay or and as far as you know
jennifer's never giving you details
about his employment or anything like
that i believe she may have mentioned he
got laid off and was in between jobs at
one point i remember that yes okay um as
far as john not talking to you about
ethan frequently that wasn't something
that um rubbed you as strange correct no
um
there was no time where you ever went to
jennifer and said i'm i'm really
concerned about your son or the way you
handle or don't handle your son is that
correct
that's incredible
your relationship with jennifer just
isn't one where that kind of
conversation would be normal
that's a fair statement yes
you testified um that you were in
complete shock is that correct
at least yes
um did you when in talking to jennifer
on the phone calls and
um
through the text messages
did you have an opinion about whether
she seemed like she was in shock
they asked you when she was on the phone
yeah or through the text messages
well i can't speak to how she felt in
the task on the phone she definitely
signed a transition as if she was
um
and when um the prosecution asked you
about
the text where jennifer said i need my
job please don't judge me for what my
son did
um you recall that text correct
and you testified that you thought it
was strange to be worried about that
with everything going on is that correct
yes
it's fair to say that you don't know
what she was worried about in that
moment
um except for in part her job correct
what
she had called us prior to that letting
us know that
she was at the police station and saw
our son figured she was worried about
her child
okay so we can agree that while she was
worried about her job she could have
been worried about many other topics at
the same time
sure yes okay and
um in your conversations with her you
did understand her to be worried about
other things such as ethan
um being at the police station
lawyers things along those lines
that was where she was worried about her
son yes
ryder i have nothing further for miss
crumbling this time any questions of
any uh cross board james comey
mr smith at some point did you have a
chance to go back and look at that
worksheet
at some point yes i did when did you do
that
later that afternoon and what did you
did you look at it in detail
yes i looked at it after we learned of
what had happened and what was your
thought about it
it's trouble
it's concerning
it's a concerning message it looks like
someone's trying for help
when you say that it looks like someone
uh asking for help
um that could be a concern of suicide is
that correct
i'm not sure i can't say i think sure i
guess yes when someone writes um help me
and my life is useless
that was concerning us
thank you
briefly your honor did you see the
picture of the gun
yes did you know that it was identical
to the fun that they bought their son no
okay
did you step down
any uh
witnessed the excuse
yeah any objection okay no
i'm gonna take i'm gonna take about five
minute break
okay